Jetzt ist es wieder mal so weit, es war auf allerhöchsten Zeit und wir sind wieder mal genial, tut uns furchtbar leid.
Wie immer Schauer als der Rest, also bitte keine Neid, halt die beste Band der Welt, eurer Bescheidenheit.
Haben wir euch gefehlt, habt ihr uns vermisst, ist euch jetzt klar, dass mit uns die Welt schöner ist.
Seid ihr wieder froh, na was für ein Glück, wir sagen hallo, denn wir sind zurück, wir sind da, wir sind wieder da.
Wir lungern nur im Schul- und Rufverkauf und kleinen Kindern kreik, wir singeln unsichtige Lieder und ihn haben zwei Welten.
Tischmanieren sind uns fremd, wir essen selten mit Besteck, die Plattenfirma schickt uns jedes Jahr ein Dingchen.
Haben wir euch gefehlt, habt ihr uns vermisst, ist euch jetzt klar, dass mit uns die Welt schöner ist.
Wir haben Hagelsturm an einem Sommertag, wir haben plötzlich Ameskon in der schönsten Melodie.
Die einen Finchern, die anderen Finchern.
Ich glaube jedes Jahr, wir sind wieder da.
Wir sind wieder da, wir sind wieder da.
Das hat jetzt irgendwie eine Minute gelaggt und auf einmal war das Stream da.
Aber wobei, doch Chat funktioniert.
Sehen wir ja, wir können nämlich einfach hier gucken.
Videos sind vorübergehend nicht empfohlen.
Okay, Twitch ist kaputt.
Am Arsch vorbei.
Irgendwie ist Twitch kaputt.
Alter, die Clips gehen?
Jetzt geht's, okay, ich glaube das hat einfach nur rumgespackt.
So Leute, ich dachte mir eigentlich, ich mach mal wieder meine Ärzte-Playlist an.
Die ist ja mittlerweile ziemlich lang, wenn man hier sieht.
Ist ja fast alles gute drinnen.
Aber Amazon war der Meinung, die Hälfte der Musik gibt es nicht mehr.
Wozu habe ich überhaupt das Abo, wenn es die Hälfte der Musik einfach random nicht mehr gibt?
Wo ist da der Sinn?
Warum ist einfach das Best-of-Album weg?
Und warum ist auf einmal Geräusch weg?
Warum ist Jazz ist anders weg?
Warum ist die Hälfte der Musik weg?
Was ist mit der Amazon los?
Und so gebe ich das Geld dafür aus.
Übrigens, der Viewer-Account geht auch nicht.
Spackt rum.
Lulve.
Irgendwie ist kaputt.
Sowohl Twitch als auch Amazon hier.
Ich geb mir das voll ab, dass die hier das hier nicht...
Dass die hier eine ganze Musik gelöscht haben.
Geht mir voll auf den Kicks.
Soll ich jetzt alle zwei Wochen oder so meine Playlist neu zusammenstellen, bis ich das dann mal wieder alles drinne hab?
Wobei manche Alben gibt es ja gar nicht mehr.
Hast du eigentlich einen Stream Deck, mit dem du Emotes per Knopfdruck einplanen kannst?
Sehen, das ist was selbst programmiertes.
Big Brain Time.
Das ist jetzt Musik für Q-Chat.
Die Viewer aktualisieren auch nicht.
Also, irgendwas ist hier huge am Arsch.
Ich starte mal kurz meinen Browser neu, mal gucken, ob das irgendwas bringt.
Das ist ein Lied für dich, weil du stundenlang zu Hause sitzt und brennst.
Ein Lied nur für dich, weil du alle unsere Texte kennst.
Kommst du aus Hamburg oder aus Berlin?
Kommst du aus Berlin oder kommst du aus Berlin?
Wir aktualisieren bei euch die Viewer bzw. läuft Twitch normal.
Ok, das bugt nämlich übelst rum.
Wenn ihr die Seite reloadet, geht's.
Ja, Twitch hängt.
Ja, es hat übelste Probleme.
Dann hoffen wir mal, dass das Content-IT-System auch nicht geht.
Also, ich zeige euch jetzt mal was.
Wo habe ich denn die Bilder?
Die Quali ist jetzt auf einmal viel schlechter.
Windows, warum ist Windows so scheiße?
Jetzt mal ganz ehrlich Leute, was ist das für ein Crap?
Warum verkackt er das jetzt?
Ok, kann man vielleicht einfach in der Anzeige...
Warum kann ich jetzt...
Ah, hier kann man drehen.
Ok, also.
Moin, Sascha Hiemi.
Was ist das Standard-Bildbearbeitungsprogramm von Linux?
Hoffen wir nicht, dass es da ein Standard-Bildbearbeitungsprogramm gibt.
Alter, Twitch ist so im Arsch.
Der Wahnsinn.
Mein Vorschau funktioniert noch nicht mal.
Jetzt die Vorschau ist auf einmal schwarz geworden.
Leute, habt ihr das zufällig gesehen oder habt ihr eine Benachrichtigung gekriegt?
Ich glaube nämlich, es haben nur ein ganz kleiner Teil der Leute Benachrichtigungen bekommen.
Ja, es hängt.
Twitch hängt mal wieder.
Benachrichtigung, ja, aber nicht alle.
Guck, Twitch hängt wieder, ist wieder offline.
Amazon, ja.
Naja, das siehst du, dass kaum einer was gekriegt hat hier, 63.
Naja, scheiß drauf.
Dann gucken wir mal, ob es besser wird, ansonsten...
Gucken wir mal, ob es besser wird, ansonsten lassen wir es bleiben.
Ich kann jetzt mal ein bisschen was zu erzählen.
Ich kann doch jetzt am Anfang alle mitkriegen.
Und zwar, ich habe ja schon vor einer Weile versucht, mal so das günstigste 10 Gigabit NAS zu bauen,
was irgendwie funktioniert, was man irgendwie zusammenbasteln kann,
beziehungsweise auch wo man auch viele Teile verwenden kann, die man noch hat.
Und da hatte ich mir Teile gekauft.
Und letztens ist ja mein Heimautomatisierungsserver verreckt.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt endlich die Kiste mal zusammengebaut,
die ich eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit zusammenbauen wollte.
Ich weiß nicht, warum da oben ein Loch drin ist, wer es schon gesehen hat.
Deswegen habe ich das jetzt hier zusammengebaut.
Und zwar ist das ein saumäßig billiges Gehäuse.
Hier fehlt übrigens auch die Abdeckung, by the way.
Ist das ein ziemlich billiges Gehäuse für irgendwie gerade mal 35 Euro oder so.
Das ist das billigste Gehäuse.
Es sieht auch billig aus.
Das ist das billigste Gehäuse, was ich gefunden habe, mit einem Wechselrahmen für zwei Festplatten drinnen.
Weil ich, wie gesagt, die Herausforderung war ja...
Das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich gar nicht anzeigen.
Weil die Herausforderung war ja, das Ganze möglichst günstig zu machen.
Und ich habe mir jetzt gedacht, okay, ich baue die Kiste jetzt mal zusammen.
Für eben 10 Gigabit Nass und vor allem als mein neuer Heimautomatisierungsserver.
Das einzig Wichtige für diese Kiste ist eigentlich, dass es viele USB-Anschlüsse hat.
Der Rest ist ziemlich egal.
Und es hat relativ viele USB-Anschlüsse.
Es hat hinten, glaube ich, sechs USB-Anschlüsse.
Da welche, da vier und da zwei irgendwie.
Es hat auf jeden Fall viele USB-Anschlüsse, also es hat relativ gute USB-Anschlüsse hinten.
Es hat hier onboard nochmal...
Man sieht es jetzt nicht so richtig.
Da vorne guckt es raus.
Es hat onboard nochmal zwei USB-3.
Da habe ich so einen Stecker drauf gemacht.
Man könnte alle Teile neu kaufen, jaja.
Also es ist keine schlechte Alternative, wenn man dann 10 Gigabit Nass haben will.
Wenn man auf 10 Gigabit verzichtet, kann man das Ganze ein bisschen ordentlicher und schöner bauen.
Aber wenn man wirklich mal 10 Gigabit Nass haben will,
ich würde mal sagen, für so 250 Euro ist das alternativlos billig.
Du kriegst für 250 Euro nirgendwo anders einen 10 Gigabit Nass.
Also Hardware, die schnell genug ist für 10 Gigabit, inklusive 10 Gigabit Netzwerkkarte und Board, Netzteil und alles.
Das Board kostet irgendwie 70 Euro oder 65 Euro.
Die Netzwerkkarte muss man gucken, dass man die günstig kriegt.
Kommt so auf die 30 Euro.
Dann nochmal ein bisschen RAM oben drauf.
Das Netzteil.
Vielleicht ist man sogar für unter 250 Euro.
Aber mit dem Gehäuse, so 200 bis 250 Euro, natürlich ohne Platten, ganze Nasspreise sind immer ohne Platten.
Das ist wirklich konkurrenzlos billig.
Natürlich, wie gesagt, das Gehäuse ist mega hässlich.
Also ich will ja der 19 Zoll Rack Gehäuse unbedingt haben.
Warum kann man jetzt eigentlich nicht die Bilder vor und zurück machen?
Aber wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt, also das ist schon ganz schön im Arsch.
Hier ist die Abdeckung irgendwie nicht bündig, wobei da kommt noch eine Abdeckung drauf.
Die habe ich irgendwo hingeschmissen.
Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht genau wo.
Das sieht halt auch für eine 19 Zoll Gehäuse echt mega scheiße aus, das Ding.
Aber es ist okay.
Und das kostet halt nix.
Der ganze Kram kostet halt nix im Endeffekt.
So und hallo.
Ah, Gott.
Windows, ey.
Ich wollte übrigens demnächst mal ein Video machen, was mich an Windows nervt.
Und nicht so diese üblichen Sachen mit, oh ja hier Datenschutz und Orkutana.
Sondern so die kleinen Sachen, die unter Windows total unverständlicherweise so kacke sind, wie sie sind.
Zum Beispiel, dass man in diesem Bild viewer nicht zwischen den Bildern hin und her schalten kann,
wenn man reingezoomt ist.
Warum, Microsoft?
Warum?
Kann man da für Sachen einsenden?
Ja klar, warum nicht?
Du kannst mir jetzt auch einfach sagen, was dir da auf den Keks geht.
Oder schreibst in Themenvorschläge im Discord, das ist auch eigentlich nicht schlecht.
Also so kleine Sachen halt.
Zum Beispiel, dass die Suche hier im Startmenü abkackt.
Oftmals.
Die finden da einfach Sachen nicht.
Das ist auch übelst fail.
Oder, dass man jetzt multiple Desktops hat.
Aber das einzige, was an virtuellen Desktops nicht virtualisiert ist, ist der Desktop.
Also sprich, man hat verschiedene Desktops, aber man hat immer den gleichen Desktop.
Versteht man, was ich meine?
Es sind zwar virtuelle Desktops, aber es ist kein unterschiedlicher Desktop.
Welches Big Brain bei Microsoft hat sich das denn ausgedacht?
Dann, was man hier unten auch schon gerade irgendwo gesehen hat, ist...
Ich mein...
Tempo the Badass Elephant.
Was macht das da?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist.
Hatte ich anscheinend mal auf irgendwann.
Warum? Was soll das sein?
Was mir auch auf den Keks geht, dass so eine Kacke hier teilweise installiert ist.
Was soll das? Warum ist das da drauf?
Bist du gerade auf einer VM? Nee.
Also mega bescheuert.
Es gibt noch so viele andere Sachen unter Windows, die mich nerven.
Das ist beispielsweise, dass es keinen Paketmanager gibt.
Dass kein brauchbares Terminal dabei ist.
Das kommt vielleicht bald, aber das ist halt auch nicht...
Schon seit 20 Jahren kein brauchbares Terminal.
Kein SSH dabei ist.
Doch, doch, SSH gibt es, glaube ich, mittlerweile auch zum Nachherzählen.
Dass kein Teller dabei ist, was man erstmal mega umständlich installieren muss.
Was mir auch total auf den Keks geht.
Warum?
Wo ist es denn jetzt?
Was auch? Guckt mal, Leute.
Wo ist der Sinn?
Kann mir irgendjemand erklären, wo der Sinn davon ist, zwei dieser Apps zu haben?
Warum gibt es das doppelt?
Das geht mir auch.
Windows 10 ist so ein zusammengeflicktes Stück Dreck,
was Usability, grafische Oberfläche angeht.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Ja genau, und Windows sagt jetzt, dass das Terminal brauchbar wird,
unterstützen wir halt immer mehr vermehrt Linux.
Was natürlich die beste Variante ist.
Weil die Linux-Shales und Terminals eh haushoch überlegen sind.
PowerShell ist nicht schlecht.
Aber was ist denn ein Machine-Wide-Installer?
PowerShell ist keine interaktive Shell.
PowerShell ist eher eine Automatisierungsumgebung.
Ja, das kenne ich. Das kenne ich.
Skirata, das kenne ich.
Aber warum gibt es das nicht von Microsoft?
Außerdem ist Schoko auch ziemlich eklig irgendwo.
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil Microsoft keine ordentlichen Installer hat,
wie diesen Wizard-Krempel da.
Das sind alles so ein paar Sachen, die mich an Windows unnötig nerven.
Auch diese Inkonsistenz hier.
Warum ist das doppelt? Warum ist das doppelt und dreifach?
Warum ist die Darstellung und Optionsvielfalt in der alten App besser als in der neuen?
Warum kann ich das hier nur über die, oder ist das hier das Gleiche?
Das sind wieder zwei unterschiedliche Sachen.
Oh, jetzt habe ich euch ausgeblendet. Wartet mal kurz.
So, wieder am Stab.
Ja, es ist einfach Fail.
Anstatt den Krempel ordentlich einheitlich zu machen,
sahen sich eher so komische Dinge aus, wie dass der Calculator jetzt den Hintergrund transparent haben kann.
Da hat die Welt drauf gewartet, oder Leute?
Habt ihr nicht auch schon immer mal den Calculator über irgendwas Plaus geschoben
und habt dann gesagt, krass Microsoft, der Calculator ist jetzt transparent.
Poggers, Alter, ist das geil.
Der Calculator, guck dich das mal an, der Calculator ist transparent.
Meine Güte, ist das geil, ist das geil.
Alles andere ist egal, Hauptsache der Calculator ist transparent.
Und der ist auch noch so unauffällig transparent, dass es wahrscheinlich kaum einer checkt.
Dann ist so ein Crap noch wie ein Notepad drauf,
was für eine Oldschool-Anwendung ist, die nicht transparent ist.
Es ist so inkonsistenter Scheiß-Windows mittlerweile, es ist der absolute Wahnsinn.
Microsoft macht viele Sachen richtig, ihre ganze.NET Core-Geschichte finde ich cool,
weil es gerade einer im Chat schreibt, ich habe jetzt keine Ahnung, was der Viewer-Account angeht,
deswegen kann ich jetzt auch ranten, ohne dass Leute, ohne dass es weniger Viewer werden,
weil ich sehe es ja einfach nicht.
Das ist absolut Next-Level-Shit.
Wie gesagt, Microsoft macht da vieles richtig,
auch dass sie immer mehr Sachen Open Source machen.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass alles, was Microsoft kacke ist,
aber Windows als Betriebssystem ist, was Usability angeht.
Ich will gar nicht mal so sagen, dass die technische Grundlage mega kacke ist,
da haben sie viel gemacht in den letzten Jahren,
aber das, was man eben als die Benutzer-Interaktion ist,
das ist einfach halb nicht ganz zu Ende gedacht unfertiger Kram.
Und das ist einfach nervig, weil das ist ja letztendlich auch das, was ist mit Twitch los,
ich habe keine Ahnung, Lisa, ich frage mich auch die ganze Zeit, was da los ist.
Und zumindest ist es einfach Müll, so wie Windows ist,
also aktuell von der Oberfläche.
Ich finde, das hier ist das beste Beispiel für,
dass du beispielsweise hier andere Sachen machen kannst als hier,
aber so basic-mäßig eigentlich, dass hier die gleiche Anwendung ist.
Das Startmenü ist übrigens auch bescheuert.
Wer hat sich gedacht, dass es eine gute Idee ist,
hier so kategorielos den ganzen Krempel rein zu droppen.
Kategorielos ist okay, wenn ich suche.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier reingehe und sage beispielsweise Steam,
dann ist es okay, dass es keine Kategorien hat,
dass es mir das random alles anzeigt, was besser passt,
wobei es mir übrigens auch gar nicht alles anzeigt.
Aber wer hat sich gedacht, alphabetisch ist eine gute Variante,
weil ganz ehrlich Leute, wo würdet ihr Chrome suchen?
Ich habe es jetzt schon gespoilert, weil jetzt weiß es jeder, wenn ich das so sage,
wo würdet ihr Chrome suchen, unter Chrome unter C oder unter G wie Google Chrome?
Ja natürlich ist es G wie Google Chrome,
aber instinktiv guckt man erstmal unter C wie Chrome.
Und dann gibt es auch noch so halbe halbe.
Hier gibt es beispielsweise die Programme ungeordnet,
außer manche Ordner, die sind dann wieder unter E,
aber Game Capture ist in E wie Elgato drinne.
Es ist total, weißt du, wenn es E unter Elgato wäre,
dass es quasi ein Alias wäre und noch mal unter G wie Game Capture.
Es ist mir wirklich komplett unverständlich.
So, dann kommt noch dazu, dass Microsoft immer undurchdachten, unfertigen Kram einführt.
Zum Beispiel haben sie sich mal gedacht, hey, es wäre doch wieder mal ganz cool,
wenn man eine ordentliche Kontaktliste hätte.
Also sowas, was man mit CalDAF beispielsweise unter Android, iOS, Mac, Linux schon ewig machen kann,
hat sich Microsoft gedacht, okay, wir müssen das besser machen.
Wir führen jetzt diese komische People, oh fuck, ich weiß nicht, was ich da aufgemacht habe,
aber ich will es hier aufmachen.
Wir führen jetzt diese komische People-App ein,
die von der Idee her ganz gut ist, die aber nichts kann.
CalDAF kann ich auch noch mit sehr vielen hängen und würgen.
Der Kalender kann standardmäßig kein CalDAF, ich will keine iCloud oder so verwenden.
Das ist das Standard, das unterstützt jedes, bloß Microsoft nicht.
Und der Hit ist die To-Do-App, die es irgendwie gar nicht mehr gibt.
Die To-Do-App, also man muss erstmal auch dazu sagen, dass es unter Windows keine To-Do-App dabei ist.
Die Standard-Ausstattung unter jedem Betriebssystem ist sowas wie ein halbwegs ordentlicher Texteditor,
ein halbwegs ordentliches Mailprogramm, ein halbwegs ordentlicher Kalender,
Kontakteverwaltung, To-Do-Programm, bisschen minimal vielleicht,
Bilder ordentlich anschauen, rotieren, croppen, rotaten.
So wisst ihr so die kompletten Basics. Ich erwarte gar nicht, dass jetzt wahnsinnig gute Programme dabei sind,
mit denen ich alles machen kann standardmäßig bei einer neuen Installation.
Aber ich mein, alles was unter Windows dabei ist, was unter Windows 10 mittlerweile dabei ist,
ist ja, müsst man ja fast sagen, ist ja sogar schon von der Funktion her ein Rückschritt zu das,
was beispielsweise unter, hey selbst unter Windows 98 das Mailprogramm war besser.
Ich mein, Outlook Express war für'n Arsch, aber Windows 10 Mail ist ja mal, das kann man doch nicht mal, das kann man doch nicht mal für'n Arsch nennen.
Nee, nee, also da war, ich weiß nicht, was da abgeht mit Microsoft. Das ist voll Pepega-Style.
Ach ja, der Explorer, ja der Explorer ist natürlich auch Müll.
Obwohl ich sagen muss, dass sie da ganz okay mittlerweile das gemacht haben.
Aber zum Beispiel, was auch nervig ist, dass der Explorer sich selbst vervollständigt mit Orten, die man aufmacht.
Das Problem ist jetzt, also egal ob die wichtig sind oder nicht, das Problem ist jetzt, dass unter meinem Main-Account,
also das hier ist ja mal ein Streaming-Account, das unter meinem Main-Account, hier unter Quick Access, kann ich hier zwei Seiten runterscrollen
und ich hab viermal Desktop drinstehen. Viermal.
Alles unterschiedliche Desktops, aber ich weiß nicht, welcher welcher ist, wenn ich ihn anklicke.
Das ist auch absolut Big Brain. Ach, das ist Fortnite Event, okay.
So, ähm, dann, das Ding kann glaub ich immer noch keine Tabs.
Das Ding kann glaub ich immer noch keine Tabs.
Und das hier oben ist ja gut, das hier oben, das ist Geschmackssache, aber für mich ist das persönlich auch eine Zumutung.
Das hier.
So, genug Windows-Rant jetzt, aber ehrlich Leute, es ist nicht schön, es ist echt nicht schön.
Ähm, ich fänd's so cool, wenn ich spielen könnte unter Linux.
Es ist unter Linux wirklich nicht alles rosig, ja.
Ähm, es gibt viele Programme unter Linux nicht.
Beispielsweise, wenn man eine richtig schöne Bildbearbeitung sucht, ich red jetzt nicht von GIMP, sondern irgendwas, was man gut bedienen kann, was günstig ist,
sowas wie beispielsweise diese Affinity-Dinger, Affinity-Photo, Affinity-Designer, das ist wirklich für Noobs wie mich super Programme.
Ich bin nicht sonderlich gut, was Bild- oder Design-Geschichten angeht, aber selbst damit kann ich halbwegs brauchbare Netze erstellen.
Sowas gibt's halt unter Linux nicht, ja.
Sowas wie Sony Vegas gibt's unter Linux nicht.
Und was es da für unter Linux gibt, sind solche Render-Geschichten wie Blender und sowas, die funktionieren da fast schon besser als unter Windows.
Aber es ist nicht alles rosig unter Linux, ja.
Die machen sich auch teilweise richtig das Leben schwer und es ist auch an vielen Stellen viel kryptischer, als es sein müsste.
Warum ich übrigens auch der Meinung bin, warum sich Linux auf dem Desktop nie durchsetzen wird.
Aber das, was Microsoft hier macht, ist auch nicht gut.
Ja, aber Video-Bearbeitungsprogramm ist einfach so, die Leute bleiben immer bei dem, was sie kennen.
Mache ich, mache ich auch.
Und solche Sachen hier tragen nicht dazu, dass man hier mehrere Apps mit den gleichen Funktionen hat.
Ich mein, außerdem, was auch noch so ein Punkt ist, ja, was auch ein riesen Rückschritt ist, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das noch kennt, unter Windows XP.
Unter Windows XP konntest du, wenn du wolltest, ich hab das so gut wie nie gemacht, aber du konntest dein komplettes Betriebssystem stylen, wie du willst, ja.
Also es ist vollkommen egal, wie der, also du konntest die Fenster stylen, Ordner stylen, Taskbar stylen, hier unten das, du konntest alles stylen.
Was du aktuell machen kannst, ist, unter Windows 10, ist nichts.
Es ist nichts, was du machen kannst, customizable.
Es ist nichts.
Ja.
Das ist halb bitter.
Und teilweise ist es sogar so schlecht, dass wenn du die falsche Farbe einstellst, man hier manche Sachen nicht sieht.
Was ist das?
Ah, ich wollte grad sagen, das klingt wie Wind Waker.
Okay, ich glaube, ich hab jetzt genug über Windows gemerkt, oder?
Oder was sagt ihr?
Ich mein, ich kann noch zwei Stunden weitermachen, dann geh ich ins Bett, easy, ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Haben wir hier überhaupt noch ein aktuelles Ubuntu Image?
Ubuntu?
Haben wir noch Ubuntu drauf?
Starten wir mal vor MWR.
Es geht jetzt nicht alles schlecht unter Windows 10.
Oh ey, Windows 98.
Teufelweiche, Alter, geh weg.
Wind Rack, Wind Rack kenn ich keiner, der Wind Rack sagt.
Das hab ich noch nie gehört.
Wind Rack find ich auch sehr unkreativ.
Oh, es hängt.
Wir abschießen das Ganze.
So.
Twitch, ja, Twitch ist kaputt.
Mein Viewer-Account-Actualität auch nicht.
Findest du VR immer besser als VirtualBox und wenn ja, warum?
Ich find's einfach runder von der Bedienung her.
Ansonsten, man kann mit VirtualBox auch alles machen, was man will.
Ich find die 3D-Unterstützung ist ein bisschen besser, sofern man's braucht.
Und, ähm, die, die Bedienung find ich schöner.
Aber ansonsten macht es eigentlich für einfachen, ab und zu mal irgendwie was virtualisieren keinen großen Unterschied.
Ich find, ich find's einfach schöner.
Ähm, deswegen hab ich auch mal die Kohle ausgegeben.
Kenn es nur Monka, Monka Vinn, ja.
Richtig, Monka Vinn.
Haben wir hier in Download noch ein Ubuntu-Image?
Haben wir.
Wobei wir brauchen gar kein Ubuntu-Image.
Ich hab ja schon einen, einen USB-Stick hier liegen.
Also ich zeig euch jetzt mal, was ich, was ich machen will.
Und zwar, ähm, ich wollte, ich hab, nachdem ich jetzt erst mal ewig über Windows gerantet hab.
Wie gesagt, ich hab jetzt die Kiste ja zusammengesteckt.
Ähm, ich hab jetzt die Kiste ja zusammengesteckt.
Ähm, ich mach, ich mach da auch morgen ein Video zu, wo, wo wir das Ganze noch mal zusammenbauen.
Und zwar, was da jetzt, was da jetzt drinne ist.
Wie gesagt, Ziel ist, das soll zuverlässig sein, aber so günstig wie möglich.
10 Gigabit, äh, Netzwerk und, ähm, so viele USB-Anschlüsse, wie irgendwie geht.
Das ist, das ist das Wichtigste.
Weil für meine Heimautomatisierung brauch ich viele USB-Anschlüsse.
Ja, weil alle möglichen, äh, Geräte oder irgendwelche Funksachen sind halt USB.
Ja.
Heißt, ich brauch den, den, den, den Stick für die Rollen.
Ich brauch den Stick für Funk.
Ich brauch den Stick für Z-Wave.
Ich brauch, äh, brauch ich noch?
Vielleicht war's da sogar schon.
Das war übelst voll, das andere Board.
Das kann nicht alles sein.
Ich hab jetzt irgendwas vergessen.
Ach ja, für die Backup-Platte.
Ähm...
Jetzt brauch ich noch.
Steht grad voll auf dem Schlauch.
Das alte Board war voll.
Ist auch egal.
So, jetzt brauch ich viele USB-Anschlüsse.
Und...
Das passt hier ganz gut.
Wie gesagt, onboard zwei USB, hinten vier oder sechs USB.
Hier nochmal zwei USB-2-Anschlüsse, also mehr als genug USB.
Deswegen ist das Gehäuse ganz nett, das Board ganz nett.
Ähm...
Nee, Tastatur mach ich da nicht dran.
Das ist ja komplett headless, das ganze Ding.
Zum Installieren mach ich das nur dran.
Und, ähm...
Ich hab mir gedacht, okay, ich bau das jetzt mal alles zusammen.
Ich hab's ja vor ner Weile gebaut.
Und ich finde, so für 200 Euro, 250 Euro,
eine 10-Gigabit, äh, 10-Gigabit-Kiste,
die potentiell, sag mal mal, so zwei Drittel von 10 Gigabit ausnutzen kann,
mit nem, mit nem Hotswap-fähigen, äh, Wechsel-, Wechsel-Rahm-Ding,
für zwei Platten und viele USB-Anschlüsse.
Mehr kann man für das Geld wirklich nicht, nicht wollen.
Übrigens, ich hab mir jetzt einen Apple S-, also ich hab jetzt für meine Mutter einen Apple SE gekauft,
und, und Aldi Talk, weil man's hier gerade sieht.
Das haben wir doch letztens im Stream geguckt.
Die hat, die hat ja die ganze Zeit erzählt, so nach dem Motto,
oh nee, mein Samsung Club-Handy, das ist das Benny Siemens.
Samsung Siemens Club-Handy.
Äh, nee, nicht Club-Handy, Siemens.
Und alles Ding halt, oh, das ist das Allerbeste und ich will gar nichts anderes.
Und jetzt, wo sie das Apple-Ding hat, sagt sie, sie weiß gar nicht, was sie vorher gemacht hat.
Ja.
Deswegen liegt hier ein bisschen Aldi Talk rum.
Äh, ja, ja, iPhone, iPhone SE, genau.
Das gab's bei eBay günstig für, glaube, 100, 110 Euro oder so,
inklusive Versand, oder 120 Euro inklusive Versand, das war halt übelst billig.
Stand zwar dran neu, ähm,
es war nicht wirklich neu, weil es kam nicht im original Verpackung.
Und wenn du drauf geguckt hast, war das halt, ähm,
schon ein bisschen benutzt.
Aber für 110 Euro kannst du da eigentlich nichts sagen.
Die ganzen Apple-Dinger sind halt gebraucherschweineteuer.
Leider, leider werden die nicht mehr fortgeführt, ja.
Es gibt ja die Vermutung, dass bald ein Apple SE, ein iPhone SE Nachfolger rauskommt.
Der wird dann aber wahrscheinlich so groß sein wie das iPhone 8,
weil die ja das alte Zeugs recyceln wollen.
Eine Maus spackt übrigens hier übelst rum, auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Ich lasse die nochmal kurz neu sinken.
Spackt immer noch rum.
Liegt das vielleicht an der Maus hier?
Ja, es liegt an der Maus hier, cool.
Da kann eine andere Maus.
Was ist das für eine Musik? Das ist, äh,
Relaxing Video Game Music aus, äh, das ist Tales of Vesperia, glaube ich.
2009, 20, 50, ähm, ja, Tales of Vesperia.
Ein schönes Ayaya-Game für die ganzen Ayaya-Fans unter uns.
Danach kommt noch mehr Ayaya, noch mehr Ayaya, noch mehr, und hier hört es dann auf.
So, und deswegen, warum kann ich bringen es nicht rein zum,
so, und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, ähm,
jetzt wo ich das Ding halbwegs zusammengeschustert habe,
werde ich mal Ubuntu drauf installieren,
und so ein bisschen Basic Setup machen,
also sprich, ich werde Homo System installieren,
ich werde, ähm, erst mal überlegen, was muss ich denn überhaupt machen.
Ähm, ich werde so die Basic Sachen installieren,
Basic Überwachungsgeschichten,
ich installiere Docker drauf, Home Assistant,
äh, Doku, Wiki, Samba, Nextcloud,
das ist alles, was man braucht, immer SQL-Datenbank,
für, für Home Assistant, ja, das war's,
im Großen und Ganzen, dann ein bisschen, ein bisschen konfigurieren, ähm,
weil, wie gesagt, ich will das ja als, als NAS und als
Home-Automatisierung-Server verwenden.
Jaja, Serious Max ist voll kaputt, Twitch,
deswegen, äh, der Viewer-Account aktualisiert auch nicht,
und ich gehe davon aus, dass, dass, dass kaum einer da ist,
so im Endeffekt, weil die Benachrichtigungen haben nicht richtig funktioniert,
die Twitch lädt bei den Leuten nicht, es ist irgendein Fortnite-Turnier,
deswegen, wir werden jetzt ein bisschen sinnloses Zeug machen.
So, was ich jetzt machen muss, ist,
ich muss jetzt erstmal hier die,
erstmal Ubuntu installieren,
und es wird ein bisschen komplizierter,
bei mir sind es immer noch 59 Viewer,
ähm, 123, das ist, das stimmt nicht,
und außerdem, wie gesagt, es ist Fortnite,
und die Benachrichtigungen gingen auch nicht raus,
ist auch, ist auch egal, ich mein,
ganz ehrlich, ich hab jetzt so lang gestreamt,
ähm, weil ich halt auf YouTube nichts gesagt habe,
ähm, mit, mit teilweise, sagen wir mal,
so 50 bis 100 Leuten,
das, das war immer,
ich brauch, ich brauch nicht immer 300 oder 350 oder so,
morgen haben wir wieder durch, mit, mit einfachem Nichtstun wieder 330 oder so,
peak, ähm,
das ist schon okay,
solange der Q-Chat am Start ist,
dann ist alles gut.
Hab ich euch übrigens schon erzählt,
was man schönes mit seinem Amazon Prime, äh, Abo machen kann.
Wenn ihr nämlich ein Amazon Prime Abo habt,
und den Durchschnitts IQ des Chats ein bisschen steigern wollt,
dann nehme ich natürlich gerne euren Twitch Prime Sub.
Erstens Big IQ für Chat, Big IQ für euch,
ja,
und, ähm, ihr habt so noch die Chance einen Streamer eurer Wahl zu supporten,
ohne dass es euch was kostet.
Muss nicht ich sein,
aber ich nehm's natürlich auch gern.
Subgen geht nicht, ja, ich hab gehört,
ich hab gehört, Leute,
wenn man, das macht tolle Geräusche, wenn man den Subbutton klickt,
das ist, das ist so der klassische Bait von YouTube früher.
Was für ein neuer Sound, wenn man Like drückt,
richtig blöd, wie die Leute dann immer drauf reingefallen sind,
erkennt ihr das noch?
Der ist nur leider gerade nicht mal im UI.
Tatsächlich.
Bei mir geht er, bei mir geht der Subbutton auch nicht.
Wenn ich drauf klinge, passiert nichts.
Twitch ist echt kaputt.
Ist das Kirby?
Ach nee, Earthborn ist das.
Ist das Earthborn?
Nee.
Oder?
Ach komm, Animal Crossing.
So, ich schließ mal kurz, ich schließ mal kurz die, ähm,
die Regato Capture, Capture Card an.
Ich muss mal kurz aufstehen zu.
Ich lasse im Hintergrund mal kurz die,
Capture Card.
Ah.
Ups.
Ich hab, ich hab Reset und Power On vertauscht
und ich wundere mich die ganze Zeit, warum es nicht geht.
Richtig Next Level Big Brain, ja.
So, da sollte jetzt eigentlich ein Ubuntu starten,
was noch auf der SSD drauf ist.
Gucken wir mal.
Fullscreen, please.
Ubuntu, genau.
Äh.
Es hängt ein bisschen.
Ah ja, Pogu.
Login, Login auf Pogu.
Phantom1968, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Hi IQ Chat.
Ist Ubuntu deine Lieblingsdistribution?
Ähm.
Je nachdem für was.
Für Desktop verwende ich am liebsten Manjaro, Linux
und für Server, die ich so selbst betreibe,
also nicht auf der Arbeit, da müsste man Red Hat verwenden.
Verwende ich eigentlich vor allem Ubuntu.
Mir ist auch der Ubuntu Way in vielen Stellen lieber
wie der Red Hat Way.
Wo Sachen liegen, was die Fault ist und sowas.
Ähm.
Aber vom Supporter her ist natürlich Red Hat vorne.
Also ich meine, das ist nicht Support von Red Hat an sich,
sondern, äh, was Red Hat supported ist.
Also, welche anderen Hersteller Support haben,
ist für Red Hat natürlich.
Außer Oracle, die fallen natürlich immer wieder raus.
Oracle haben quasi so einen Red Hat Fork, den sie supporten.
Das heißt Oracle Enterprise Linux.
Im Prinzip das Gleiche mit ein paar Kernel-Patches.
Sie könnten ohne Probleme Red Hat verwenden,
aber Oracle ist der Meinung.
Nein, wir brauchen was Eigenes.
Ähm, jetzt muss ich erstmal den USB-Stick hier inserten.
Und dann nochmal booten.
Wartet mal.
Ach so.
Bei der Gelegenheit muss ich noch kurz meine Tastatur anstöpseln.
F***, reicht nicht, nicht lange noch.
Kabel ist nicht lange noch, das schaffst du gleich.
Oh, was hat der denn jetzt für Schmerzen hier?
Ja, nicht lange noch, genau.
Mal gucken, ob ich von USB-Stick starten kann.
Schauen wir mal.
Äh, was muss ich drücken?
F12?
Leute, was muss ich drücken für Boot-Menü?
Boot-Menü?
Okay, das war der falsche Knopf für Boot-Menü.
Ich hammer jetzt erstmal Escape zum Starten.
F10?
Meinst du echt?
F10, okay.
Wenn ich das ja ein bisschen schneller aktualisieren würde,
dann würde ich das ja ein bisschen schneller.
Oder F11?
Ich hammer einfach gleich mal alles, wenn es jetzt nicht funktioniert.
Okay, es funktioniert nicht.
Starten wir gleich mal neu.
Ich hammer jetzt einfach F10.
F10, F9, F8.
What the f***?
Okay, wo ist das Problem?
Ich glaube, jetzt habe ich das...
Oh, Screenshot?
Screenshot?
Was für ein Screenshot?
Please select Boot Device.
Das ist falsch.
Ich will vom USB-Stick booten.
Ich stöpse den USB-Stick mal hinten ans Mainboard dran.
Vielleicht spackt das rum.
So, wieder am Start.
Welcher Knopf war es denn jetzt, der eigentlich was gebracht hat?
Noch mal neu starten.
Noch mal alle Buttons hammern.
Ich hoffe, dass es funktioniert.
Hey.
Image files saved.
Kann das mal bitte aufhören, irgendwelche Images zu speichern
auf Datenträgern, die Daten enthalten.
Was soll denn das Scheiß?
Okay, if...
Oh, ifeboot von dem USB-Stick.
Alles klar.
Install Ubuntu Server, jawoll.
So muss das sein.
So, und jetzt wird es ein bisschen kompliziert.
Das habe ich jetzt schon eine Weile nicht mehr gemacht.
Wir müssen jetzt Disk Encryption einrichten.
Der sollte aber nicht einfach auf Datenträger ungefragt was schreiben.
Was ist denn das für ein Schwachsinn?
Ich meine, auf den Datenträgern sind Sachen drauf.
Wenn der einfach auf die Datenträger den Bild schreibt, macht er vielleicht was kaputt.
Okay, Language.
Englisch.
Oh, das Lack bei der Elgato.
Der erkennt meine Tastatur gerade nicht.
Warum das?
Hä?
Warum erkennt er meine Tastatur nicht?
Die hat er doch eben auch erkannt.
Ja, ja, ja.
Was ist da wieder für kompliziertes Zeug?
Jetzt erkennt er das jetzt?
Ha, jetzt gehts.
Einfach mal umgesteckt und gut ist.
Ah, perfekt.
Wir sind nicht in den United States.
Wir sind in Europa.
Und wir sind in Germany.
Da, zack.
Ich habe jetzt übelst einen Lack über die Elgato.
So, Locale Settings, US ist okay.
Keyboard darf man detekten.
Yes, press Ö.
Nee, denkst Y.
Yes, wir haben den Ö-Key.
Press Ö-Key.
No, wir haben kein French Keyboard.
Next.
Den kram kann ich mittlerweile auswendig.
IAQ Linux install.
Auswendig gelernt.
Nee, kein Baguette Key.
So, genau.
Wir müssen jetzt Lux im Setup machen.
Allerdings, ich will nicht, dass das normale Lux Setup,
beziehungsweise das normale Krypto Setup von Ubuntu,
weil der macht da immer einen LVM drüber.
Und ich finde, das ist reichlich sinnlos an der Stelle.
Ich werde da nichts erweitern oder so.
Der muss keinen LVM drüber machen.
LVM geht mir auch eher auf den Keks,
wenn ich nämlich die Platte mal in einem anderen Rechner
einhängen muss.
VAC1.
Das ist nicht mein Staubsauger.
What the fuck?
Warum kriegt der Host gerade den Namen von meinem Staubsauger?
Das kann nur irgendeine DACP-DNS-Geschichte sein,
die rumspackt.
Nein, der Host-Name ist nicht VAC1.
Das soll es nicht heißen, wie mein Staubsauger.
Der heißt POGU.
Oder?
Leute, wir brauchen einen guten Namen
für meinen neuen Heim-Automation- und NAS-Server.
Wie gesagt, da macht noch ein bisschen mehr.
Da macht Nextcloud, da macht Doku-Wiki.
Ayaya?
Soll man Ayaya nennen?
Sag mal, mach mal Vorschläge.
Pepega, Ayaya, Naissunas.
Das muss ein E-Mode-Name sein.
Ayaya-Server, ne?
Stream Fortnite, please.
Das kommt ja so ein bisschen aus dem Kontext irgendwie.
Enter im Nass, Ayaya.
Ayayare.
Magenta-Cloud-Fivehead.
Ich bin ja fast geneigt, den Fivehead zu nennen.
Oder Kekwe.
Kekwe nennen wir den.
Wobei, wir können den nicht Kekwe nennen.
Wisst ihr, warum wir den nicht Kekwe nennen können?
Weil ich, ich, ich, ich prophezeie jetzt mal wieder.
Machen wir wieder hier, Max sagt, die Zukunft vorher.
Und zwar wird Kekwe wieder abgelöst werden
durch ganz normales Null.
Kekwe, der Hype ist schon wieder vorbei.
Kekwe ist nicht mehr angesagt.
Oder immer noch angesagt, aber der ist auf dem Absteigen.
Es wird zunehmend immer wieder normales Null verwendet.
Varity Twitch Prime. Dankeschön.
Big IQ Sub.
Nice Subscriber.
Ich nenne den jetzt Ayaya.
400.
Der heißt jetzt Ayaya.
Gut, also mein neuer Home Automation Server.
Das heißt jetzt Ayaya.
So muss das sein.
Okay, Hausname ist Ayaya.
Full Name for New User.
Max.
Yes.
Passwort.
Big Prane Passwort.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Ja, Ghost Rider, aber weniger als ich müsste.
Deswegen kommt da auch noch ein Doku-Wiki drauf,
dass ich ein paar Sachen aufschreiben kann.
So die wichtigsten Sachen.
Zum Beispiel, in welcher Reihenfolge ich welche Platten einhängen müsste.
Oder an welchem Port welche Platte mit welcher Seriennummer steckt.
Und wisst ihr, warum ich so ein Kackpasswort nehme?
Weil ich danach eh Authorized Key Authentification einschalte und alles andere aus.
Deswegen nehme ich jetzt zum Setup so ein Kackpasswort.
Yes, wir wollen ein Weak Password verwenden.
Meine Zeitzone ist Europe Berlin, das ist richtig.
Install has detected following disks have mounted partitions.
Unmounted partitions that I use.
Yes.
Das kommt alles weg.
Das wird alles weg eliminiert.
Weak, also manual partitionen wollen wir.
So, das sieht natürlich...
Moment, ich bin verwirrt.
Moment, das ist eine Festplatte, das da unten...
Warum zeigt der denn den USB-Stick an, das ist ja total beknackt.
Also den USB-Stick wollen wir nicht partitionieren.
Und die externe Festplatte wollen wir auch nicht partitionieren.
Wir wollen eigentlich nur meine 2TB KUVO Samsung SSD partitionieren.
Wir machen jetzt mal alles weg.
Delete this partition.
Und dann zeige ich euch mal wie das geht.
Also ehrlich gesagt muss ich selbst gucken.
Delete this partition.
Das erste was wir machen müssen, wir machen ja EFI Boot.
Das heißt das erste was wir brauchen ist so ungefähr...
Sagen wir mal, keine Ahnung.
Moment, kann man den vielleicht...
Wow, ja ich weiß.
Kann man den vielleicht ein bisschen intelligenter selbst partitionieren lassen?
Geht das?
Nee, kann man nicht.
Okay, also wir müssen eine EFI Boot Partition machen.
Machen wir wirklich mal wie einer im Chat vorschlägt, 512 MB.
Das ist da wo alle EFI Boot Sachen drauf gespeichert sind, die man braucht.
Damit man EFI booten kann.
Ich weiß nicht wie ich das anders erklären soll.
Das ist Bare Metal.
Das ist diese Kiste hier gerade.
Moment, wo habe ich denn die Maus?
Fuck, ich kann es dir gerade nicht zeigen.
Ich kann es dir gerade nicht zeigen, weil ich die Tastatur nicht dran habe.
Das ist Bare Metal gerade.
Okay, also wir machen jetzt eine 512 MB am Anfang.
Aber das Ganze wird eine EFI System Partition.
Braucht man sonst kann man nicht booten.
Man muss auch angeben, dass es bootable sein soll, sonst funktioniert das nicht.
Ich gebe den Ding mal Name.
EFI braucht man nicht, aber ist nicht verkehrt.
Wir können das Ding auch Ubuntu nennen.
Ich weiß nicht ob das das ist, was dann auch im Bootmenü auftaucht später.
Bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ich glaube aber nicht.
Ich glaube die Bootmenü Eintrag muss man danach festlegen.
Oder macht dafür einen.
Also das ist fertig.
Warum ist da 33 MB Free Space davor?
33,5 MB, das kann ich nicht verantworten, dass wir das verschenken.
Das geht nicht.
Das müssen wir nochmal neu machen.
Create New Partition.
Da muss doch immer Space am Anfang sein, aber kein 33,5 MB.
Aber wir machen jetzt einfach 500 MB und gucken mal wie viel am Anfang bleibt.
EFI System Partition.
Okay, muss das echt sein?
Vielleicht bin ich ja auch der Kacknoob, warum muss das 33,5 MB immer sein am Anfang?
Kann mir das jemand erklären?
Was macht das da?
Warum muss das so sein?
Wir machen eine neue Partition Table.
Das könnte Alignment sein.
Ja gut, aber wenn ich die richtig größer nehmen müsste, das mit dem Alignment doch eigentlich hinhauen.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt mal was.
Wir sagen jetzt Automatic.
Okay, es ist immer 33,5 MB am Anfang frei.
Okay, das ist der Bundestreuer.
Na ja, das wird es sein.
Na ja gut, dann ist es okay.
Kann ich mitleben?
Also machen wir das jetzt mal.
Create New Partition.
Wir machen jetzt 500 MB, das reicht.
Alter, ich kann nicht tippen, 500 MB für die EFI System Partition.
Ist schon ausgewählt, jawoll.
Jetzt wird es interessant.
Jetzt müssen wir eine Create New Partition machen.
Ich mache jetzt ein Gigabyte Boot Partition.
Ich bin mir nämlich nicht sicher, wie viele Kernel standartmäßig behalten werden.
Ich hatte letztens ein Problem bei einer meiner Kisten, da es die Boot Partition vollgelaufen ist, weil die zu klein war.
Die war auch schon 500, 600 MB.
Deswegen mache ich jetzt mal ein Gigabyte.
Klar, es ist kein Problem, man kann einfach starten und alte Kernel löschen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich will da eigentlich gar nichts machen.
So, Boot drauf.
Lustigerweise, Boot muss selbst nicht bootable sein.
Weil normalerweise schon, glaube ich zumindest.
Klassisches Partitionieren und BIOS booten muss bootfähig sein.
Aber ich glaube, wenn du es über EFI machst, dann nicht.
Jetzt wird es interessant.
Hier müssen wir jetzt eine neue Partition anlegen.
Die kann den restlichen Speicher belegen.
Und da mounten wir jetzt nicht was direkt drauf, sondern sagen ihm, dass wir das usen wollen für Volume Encryption.
So, Name.
Entweder Enk.
So, die Default Settings sind okay, das passt alles.
Das Ding hat auch IES-Beschleunigung in der CPU.
Das heißt, das ist schön zackig.
So, fertig.
Interessant, dass er trotzdem 2TB.
Ich lösche das nochmal, ich will mal was ausprobieren.
Delete this Partition.
Ich will noch mal was ausprobieren.
Was passiert denn, wenn ich ihm sage, mach automatisch?
Macht er dann?
Dann macht er 2TB und macht das gleiche.
Okay, fast das gleiche.
Nur, dass er schon direkt was anlegt.
Na gut.
Und zwar, wir wollen das, wie gesagt, nicht als Systempartition formatieren, sondern, äh, wir formatieren ja gar nichts.
Wir machen das ja bloß im Setup.
Wir sagen ihm, wir wollen das für Encryption verwenden.
So.
Done Setting Up Partitions.
Und jetzt muss man sagen, Configure Encrypted Volumes.
Also ein bisschen durch die Brust ins Auge, jawoll.
Und jetzt kann man eben sagen, Create Encrypted Volumes.
Dann nehmen wir die da.
Die da.
SDA3.
Das ist die, die wir gerade angelegt haben.
Das hier ist Boot.
Und das hier ist UEFI.
Continue.
Finish.
So, jetzt geben wir eine Passphrase ein.
Ich mach jetzt mal eine simple Passphrase.
Die werde ich aber dann austauschen auf Stream gegen was Sinnvolles.
Wir haben jetzt auch nur 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Das ist für Stream relativ easy.
Geht eigentlich Twitch mittlerweile wieder halbwegs?
Zu seinem SATA-Problem.
Ich guck mal.
Ja, die habe ich auch schon gesehen.
Aber die haben teilweise richtig schlechte Bewertungen.
Die gibt es auch bei Amazon.
Und die sehen auch echt nicht hochwertig aus.
So.
Hast du jetzt die Festplatte oder die Partition Encrypted?
Die Partition.
Und aktuell ist noch gar nichts.
Ich habe ihm nur gesagt, hier, da, mach mal.
Und jetzt muss ich noch hier innerhalb der Encrypted.
Also, ich habe ihm gesagt, hier, 200TB soll er verwenden für DM-Mapper Encryption.
Und da drinne muss ich jetzt ein File-System anlegen.
Und zwar sage ich, da soll einfach alles drinne gemountet werden.
Also, das ist jetzt die Partition, die verschlüsselt ist.
Nicht die ganze Platte.
Weil, wenn die komplette Platte verschlüsselt ist.
Also, das ist die, also, es ist alles verschlüsselt vom Betriebssystem.
Komplett.
Weil das Betriebssystem kommt hier drauf, in die verschlüsselte, in die verschlüsselte Partition.
Aber zum Booten brauche ich eine EFI-Partition unverschlüsselt und eine Boot-Partition unverschlüsselt.
Ich weiß, dass man theoretisch zumindest die Boot-Partition auch verschlüsseln kann.
Das funktioniert.
Wie es mit der EFI-Boot-Partition aussieht, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber das lohnt sich nicht so wirklich.
Ich verschlüssel mein ganzes System.
Eigentlich ist LVM und Lux ganz nett.
Gebe ich dir recht, hat seine Vorteile, aber ich benutze wahrscheinlich nichts davon.
Und mir geht es eher auf den Keks, wenn ich die Platte irgendwo anders reinhängen muss.
Dass ich dann erstmal LVM scannen muss, LVM aktivieren muss und Geschiss.
Ja, LVM an sich hat schon seine Daseinsberechtigung.
So. Passt. Alles gut.
Kann man da eigentlich auch irgendwelche Mounting-Options angeben?
Mount-Options? Oh, kann man das auch? Wusste ich gar nicht.
Sollte man trimmen? Nein, trimmen mache ich ab und zu mal.
Was ich machen will, ist...
Ich wollte diese Zeitstempel-Aktualisierung ausschalten.
Das braucht man eh nicht.
Wie hieß denn das nochmal?
Ist egal. War das No-Art-Time?
Trim-Macht-System.de, genau.
No-Art-Time wollte ich genau.
Oh, eh kein Mensch.
So, Mount is, Typical Reserve Blocks, ja, bla, sonst was.
Label braucht man nicht.
Done.
Ok, fertig.
Finish. Hab ich irgendwas vergessen? Ich glaube nicht.
Finish.
Mal gucken, ob es funktioniert. Sollte funktionieren.
Wow.
Setter, aber Boot-Partition? Hä? Hab ich doch gemacht.
Hat er das...
Das habe ich eingestellt, das hat er vergessen.
Das hat er vergessen, das habe ich doch eingestellt.
Ich habe doch eingestellt, dass er das als...
Als Boot verwendet, das habe ich doch eingestellt.
Ja, klar habe ich das eingestellt. Ich glaube, das ist ein Bug im Installer.
Kann man mit Python Home Automation machen? Klar.
Home Assistant ist komplett in Python programmiert.
Warum setzt du eigentlich auf Ubuntu?
Ja gut, zwischen Demian und Ubuntu ist jetzt auch nicht so der wahnsinnige Unterschied.
Ich mag eigentlich die Default-Sachen von Ubuntu.
Und was ich ganz gern habe, ist das Zeug, das sie mitliefern.
Sowas wie ihre LXD-Geschichte und so.
Es hat jetzt keinen speziellen Grund.
Du weißt doch, wie das ist.
Wenn man sich an was gewöhnt hat und solange man damit klarkommt
und man damit gut fährt, sieht man selten den Grund, da irgendwas zu ändern.
Okay, mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Was?
Partition assigned to boot starts at offset of 512 bytes from the minimum alignment for this disk.
Warum macht er das nicht automatisch?
Oh Gott, ich mache das jetzt nicht alles nochmal neu.
Ich mache das jetzt nicht alles nochmal neu.
Alignment spezifisch.
Das ist mir jetzt zu blöd. Yes, passt.
Yes.
Ups.
Äh.
Kann man sich dann die Alignment-Options unserer Geschichte überhaupt anzeigen lassen?
Soll ich das jetzt selbst ausrechnen oder was?
What the fuck?
Jaja, ist gut. So schlimm wird das schon mal nicht sein.
No.
Finish.
Was?
Ich darf das nicht machen oder was?
No.
Yes.
Ha, debated.
Das ist kein FAT32.
Es ist debated, es ist egal, was ich mache.
Es ist debated, Alter.
Soll ich das jetzt wirklich nochmal machen, ernsthaft, ja?
Okay, wie?
Ach.
EFI ist FAT32?
Nein, EFI ist nicht FAT32.
Oder?
Ich dachte, EFI ist EFI.
Okay.
EFI ist FAT32.
Ernsthaft?
Interessant, wusste ich gar nicht.
Ja, das ist ja ganz toll.
Jetzt darf ich den ganzen Shit nochmal machen.
Da freue ich mich aber.
Wobei, nicht ganz.
Nicht ganz, Leute, nicht ganz.
Den restlichen Kram können wir da lassen.
Delete this partition.
Yes.
Free space.
Okay, ich weiß, was wir machen.
Ich weiß, was wir machen.
Wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt Trick 17.
Wir sagen jetzt create new partition.
Wegen G.
Beginning.
Und sagen ihm, es soll Boot werden.
Und den Rest machen wir für EFI.
Gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Aber ist zu wenig, ne?
Was passiert da jetzt?
Lulbe.
EFI system partition, okay.
Geht das jetzt?
Was?
We know root file system defined.
Da ist es doch.
Irgendwie gebadet mich das Setup.
Warum steht das jetzt auf do not use?
Natürlich sollst du das usen.
Das Zeug.
Boot an Anfang.
Nicht EFI zuerst, Boot an Anfang, EFI dahinter.
Dann geht's.
So muss das sein.
Da hat er auch kein alignment Probleme irgendwie mit Boot.
Weil Boot ist einfach am Anfang.
Big brain, sag ich da nur.
So, jetzt ist der Kram hoffentlich bald installiert.
Ich kann mir den hinten installer nicht mehr angucken.
So, das ist schon 1.250.
Aber ich muss morgen nicht arbeiten gehen.
Ich muss montags nie arbeiten gehen.
Ist heute überhaupt Sonntag?
Ja.
So, danach, nachdem wir fertig installiert haben, das ist ja gleich durch.
Als erstes, was wir installieren müssen, ist Unlock.
Was ist das jetzt für Game Musik?
Das Erste, was wir machen, ist Anlocken über SSH installieren.
Das haben wir auch schon ein paar Mal im Stream gemacht.
Das ist easy, dauert 5 Minuten.
Würdest du Homocysten empfehlen?
Ja.
Homocysten ist, finde ich, das beste Heimautomatisierungs-Hub, das es gibt.
So, no automatic updates ist okay, mache ich immer von Hand.
Was wir installieren ist allerdings einen SSH-Server.
Das komme ich ja nicht drauf auf die Kiste.
Wenn da Kram installiert ist, kann ich ja nicht meine Tastatur wieder umstöpseln.
Wisst ihr Leute, das ist wirklich eine riesen Errungenschaft in SSDs, dass OS-Installationen so schnell gehen.
Wie lange man da früher rumgefuddelt hat mit Magnetfestplatten ist der Wahnsinn.
Was habe ich noch mal für ein Passwort für die Festplatte genommen?
Ich glaube, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Die gute alte Zeit, wo man Floppies in State hat.
Das habe ich nur am Rande mitgekriegt.
Wie gesagt, ich bin 1984 geboren, aber es ist nicht so, dass ich nicht Disketten hatte.
Ich habe auch mit Disketten rumhantiert.
Aber das meiste, was ich wirklich viel gesehen habe, das waren dann schon CDs.
Ich habe nur mal, was war das damals?
Porreldraw oder sowas, glaube ich, installiert von irgendwie 35 Disks, von irgendwie 35 Disketten oder sowas.
Wenn man sich überlegt, wie wenig auf so eine Diskette draufgepasst hat.
Normaler Floppy war 1,44 MB.
Es gab irgendwie mehrere.
Es gab 720 Kilobyte, 1,44 MB.
Gab es auch 2 MB Disketten?
Es gab doch jedenfalls dritte, 720, 720, 1,44, 1,44.
Gab es noch 2 MB?
Es gab so drei verschiedene, 2,88 MB.
Es gab drei verschiedene Sachen, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
PB für Vespa war 1,56.
Und danach hat man im Prinzip immer noch CDs verwendet.
Aber CDs waren auch nicht schön.
CDs waren es lahm ohne Ende, vor allem was Zugriffszeiten angeht.
Ich glaube, zu den Zeiten, wo 800 MB 1,2 GB Festplatten richtig viel waren.
Ich glaube, was jeder mal versucht hat, ist, da gab es ja so Custom Software, dass man CDs quasi als Laufwerk in Windows einbinden.
Also RW-CDs, den man bei Brenner hatte, RW-CDs als Laufwerk in Windows einbinden kann.
Und ich glaube, was damals jeder versucht hat, ist, ob er seine publicen 800 MB bzw. 1,2 GB Platte nicht erweitert kriegt.
Mit einer RW-CD.
Und das sah halt aus, unter Windows, wie ein stinknormales Laufwerk.
Aber es war halt noch langsamer.
Das hat sich überhaupt nicht gehört.
Außerdem waren RW-CDs halt ratzfatzdurch, wenn du da halt auch wirklich RAM-RW drauf gemacht hast.
Oh!
Fuck!
Und jetzt?
Okay, Crap kackt ab. Warum kackt Crap ab?
Warum?
Fuck!
Okay, wir müssen nochmal zurück zu partitionieren.
Oh!
Ich bin auf dem Sack.
F.
Wo ist das Problem?
Check ich nicht.
CentOS.
Das geht auch. Ich mach nur irgendwas verkehrt. Vielleicht ist die EFI-Partition wirklich zu klein.
What?
Hallo, ich will neu partitionieren. Warum?
Leute, hab ich...
Weiß jemand, wie man feststellen kann, ob man EFI gebootet hat?
Ich kann ja meinen Tastaturgrad nicht verwenden.
Vielleicht hab ich nicht EFI gebootet und deswegen geht's nicht.
Fuck, ich darf nichts mehr machen.
Okay.
Wir rebooten.
Ich dachte auch, dass ich EFI gebootet hab.
Okay.
Noch mal.
Ja, ich kann nur EFI booten, was anderes kann ich gar nicht booten.
Kann das nicht...
Kann es nicht mal groß schalten, please?
Okay, es hat wieder keinen Bock, sich groß zu schalten.
Crap.
Verdrückt.
Englisch.
Oh, jetzt war ich im Schnelldurchlauf.
Germany.
Lokal.
So lange hab ich noch nie für eine publische Ubuntu-Installation gebraucht.
Voll beknackt.
Okay, Leute, ich muss mal kurz das Atomsteckleister wieder Vollbild machen.
Vollbild.
So.
Fuck, der will das Ding unbedingt sein.
Nein, Aja-ja soll es so heißen.
Was benutzt du denn für 10-Gigabit-Karten?
Das ist von Melanox, Melanox Connect 3 oder so.
Ich hab ein paar von den Zweiern und ein paar von den Dreiern, weil die einfach relativ günstig sind.
War das ein Windows-Zone? Ja, war ein Windows-Zone.
Na, es läuft ja im Endeffekt hier unter Windows, ne?
Ich zeige euch halt einfach nur das in der Capture Card im Vollscreen.
Yes, alles unmounten, please.
Okay, Manual.
Also.
FAT32, das habe ich zwar überhaupt nicht eingestellt, aber gut.
Okay, wir löschen das jetzt nochmal.
Warum gibt es eigentlich keinen Button für alles? Ach doch, es gibt einen Button für alles, löschen, ganz easy.
Einfach sagen.
Neue Partitions-Tabelle, bam.
Okay, also.
Create New Partition.
Mal 512 MB.
512 MB EFI-Partition.
Off.
Dann.
Warum ist es jetzt eigentlich nur 469? Das ist doch schon mal Fail irgendwie.
Kommt, weißt du was? Scheiß drauf.
Ich hab genug Speicher.
Was macht er eigentlich, wenn ich sag Automatically Create? Da wird er es doch richtig machen, oder?
Ne, da legt er kein Boot an.
Omega Lul.
Oh Mann.
Was ein Act.
Stimmt, 1 Boot wollten wir machen. Richtig.
Habe ich schon wieder ganz vergessen.
So, 1 GB Boot muss reichen.
1 GB Boot ist mehr als genug.
Boundpoint Boot.
Das muss gehen, das reicht.
Ja, das geht mit FD wirklich fast schneller.
So, 2.
Nein, nein.
Na doch, auch gut, auch gut.
Warum ist jetzt Boot eigentlich auf einmal FAT32?
Das macht er schon. Das macht er wahrscheinlich Boot EFI automatisch.
Du kannst ja nur Boot EFI auswählen.
Nein, ich hab mich verklickt.
Hä?
Was macht er denn da?
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ja, hab ich. Ich hab EFI booted.
Use X4.
Gut, ist doch alles gut.
Okay.
So, und das hier gibt es nicht X4, sondern Krypto.
Fuddel, das hätte ich ja nie für möglich gehalten.
Okay.
Configure encrypted volumes. Yes.
Create encrypted volumes auf SDA3.
Continue. Finish.
Passwort eingeben. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Huge Passport.
So, das muss jetzt funktionieren. Also, da kann jetzt eigentlich nichts mehr großartig dran falsch sein.
Ich meine, es war vorher eigentlich auch schon nichts falsch, aber okay.
So, und jetzt müssen wir ihm sagen, wir wollen hier drinnen...
Ja, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Ehrlich.
Es hat jetzt keinen Sinn zum Ausprobieren da was komplizierteres einzugeben.
Das kann ich ja immer noch machen.
Okay. Auf geht's. Finish.
Yes.
Also, wenn es jetzt nicht funktioniert, habe ich keine Ahnung was der für Schmerzen hat.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Merkwürdig. Ich meine, es funktioniert ja alles. Außer Cropinstall. Spack drum.
Ja, Chillfreak. Stimmt. Ja, es klingt logisch.
Oder später gemountet wird es egal.
Er muss einfach irgendwelche Magic Bites wahrscheinlich auf der Platte finden, dass er booten kann.
Oder ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht woher er weiß, an welcher Stelle er anfangen muss.
Und wahrscheinlich sagt man ihm das, wenn man eben den EFI Eintrag anlegt, an welcher Stelle das auf der Platte anfängt.
Das habe ich mir noch nie so im Detail angeguckt, weil du kannst ja nicht einfach EFI booten, du musst ihm ja einen Eintrag erstellen.
Und wenn er nicht da ist, dann sucht er wahrscheinlich.
Ich kann gerade leider keine Emotes machen, weil ich die Tastatur nicht angestöpselt habe.
Aber schonmal Dankeschön für den Sub.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob es funktioniert.
Zweite Tastatur, habe ich gar keinen Platz richtig für. Ich habe rechts mein T-Stehen, links Audio-Kram.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich Tastatur hinstellen soll. Vielleicht auf die Erde vor die Kiste, wo ich es ausprobiere.
Doch, doch, ich habe eine zweite Tastatur.
Es ist bestimmt sehr spannend, mir eine Stunde bei der Ubuntu Installation zuzugucken, oder?
Absolut Next Level Stream.
Nein, keine Updates.
Updates ist overrated.
Megal.
Zumindest ist die Installation halt richtig schnell auf eine SSD. Das dauert halt keine drei Minuten, die eigentliche Installation.
Immer noch besser als Leute beim Ikea-Einkauf. Es gibt Livestreams aus Ikea?
Wirklich?
Na gut, was frage ich so blöd? Na klar, gibt es sowas.
Warum sollte sowas nicht geben?
Ich warte noch, bis sich irgendjemand beim Poppen streamt oder so.
Besser als der Fortnite Livestream. Was ist denn eigentlich gerade für ein Fortnite Zeugs am Laufen?
Neue Season, okay.
Ja, und in Deutschland wird wahrscheinlich FIFA und Slot Machine gespielt.
International, die spielen Fortnite und in Deutschland wird wahrscheinlich Slots und FIFA gespielt.
Mal gucken, ob es Ubuntu jetzt hinkriegt.
Das ist auch quasi Battle Royale, was wir hier machen. Last Man Standing.
Spielst du auch Coin Master? Coin Master ist ja out.
Ich habe leider mein Handy nicht hier, sonst könnte ich euch mal vorlesen, was ich wieder für tolle Promotion Anfragen gekriegt habe, was Mobile Games anbelangt.
Können wir machen, falls es nicht funktioniert.
Warum installiert er Open VM Tools? Das ist keine VM, das ist Metall.
Nee, das habe ich nicht.
Das mache ich auch nicht mehr.
Ich weiß schon gar nicht mehr, was da war.
Das war irgendein WLAN Skamars Repeater.
So, jetzt werde ich mal schauen, ob es funktioniert.
Wie lange Streams sind euch? Ich weiß es nicht.
Kommt davon an, hängt davon ab, ob das jetzt installiert.
Jetzt kommt Club Installation.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist nicht Chrono Trigger, oder? Nee, was ist das?
Oder doch Chrono Trigger? Nee, was ist das?
Okay, jetzt wird es ernst.
Mal gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Ach nee, Final Fantasy 6, Overworld 7 ist das.
Oh, das ist so gute Musik.
Huge Musik. Big Brain.
Davon steigt der IQ, wenn man sich das anhört.
Es hat funktioniert.
Final Fantasy 6 hatte einen wirklich unglaublich guten Soundtrack.
Ein bisschen Final Fantasy gedudelt auch bei, aber das meiste ist wirklich richtig gut.
Okay, Continue. Schauen wir mal, ob es funktioniert.
Auf gehts.
Es bootet. Huge.
Okay, Unlock, Disc, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, Bam.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht so genau, wo das Problem war, weil eigentlich haben wir nichts großartig anderes gemacht.
Außer, dass Efi ein bisschen größer war.
Aber wenn Efi eine Mindestgröße bräuchte, dann soll ich das vielleicht sagen.
Okay, Login.
Die Musik, die Final Fantasy Musik ist so wahnsinnig geil, die 6er.
1,30
Okay, auf, geh mal groß.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Konfiguration ausgedatet ist. 2,125.
Da können wir uns jetzt per SSH drauf einloggen.
Und ich kann endlich meine Tastatur wieder hochstablen.
So.
Nice.
SSH 225.
Wir sagen Option, No.
Strict, Housekey Checking, No.
Hat seinen Grund.
Das ist auch nicht Test, das ist Max.
Da sind wir.
Ah, ja, ja, sind wir eingeloggt.
Was haben wir da für eine komische Schriftart?
Sieht nicht so aus wie meine.
Accuracula angeblich.
Upgrade.
Was ist denn das für eine geile Konsole? Das ist Knob Terminal.
Knob Terminal mit Teamux und Teamaxe, wie die coolen Leute sagen.
Und im dunklen Farbschema.
Also jetzt nichts so wahnsinnig ausgefallenes.
Moin Michael, 50 Milliarden.
Streamst du heute mit dem Elgato Tool oder nimmst du das nur als HDD-Recorder?
Das ist, ach so, ne ne, gestreamt über OBS.
Das Einzige, was ich jetzt gemacht habe, ist die Vorschau von dem Elgato Tool verwendet.
Ja, also Farbschema ist das hier fürs Terminal.
Base 16 Tomorrow Night.
Und für ZSH ist exakt das gleiche Farbschema.
Das ist Secret of Mana.
Eindeutig.
Dieses, dieses, dieses Secret of Mana Ruinen, Ruinen, äh, Team.
Ach nicht Secret of Mana, fuck!
Chrono Trigger, ich hab's verwechselt.
Aber das ist glaube ich der gleiche Dude, der die Musik gemacht hat.
Ja, jetzt hätte ich's erkannt, das ist eindeutig Chrono Trigger.
Ist das Shala?
Shala oder wie die hieß, Team?
Ach nee, Corridors of Time ist das, genau.
Chrono Trigger ist, jetzt mal hands down oder wieder kabum sagen wir, Hand aufs Herz.
Chrono Trigger ist eines der besten Spiele, die jemals gemacht wurden für egal welche Konsole.
Oder egal für welche Plattform.
Also wenn ich eine Liste machen müsste, mit irgendwie so einer Top 10 Liste, mit Spielen, die mich irgendwie besonders bewegt, beeindruckt,
besonst was haben, da wäre Chrono Trigger auf jeden Fall mit dabei.
Das ist wirklich hands down eines der besten Spiele, die je gemacht wurden.
Könntest du irgendwann mal erklären, wie man das Meme Board oder den Screenshot Notificator benutzt?
Ähm, gar nicht, die Dinger sind nicht richtig fertig.
Das Meme Board gibt es nur als Version auf GitHub.
Sogar fertig, musst du einfach nur runterladen und ausführen.
Aber die kann nur die Hälfte von dem, was meine gerade kann.
Nein, das ist ein normales Gehäuse, wo nur ein Board reinpasst.
Das andere Gehäuse habe ich mir gedacht, das brauche ich nicht, weil ich brauche ja nur einen Rechner.
Ich habe das ja alles ein bisschen down gesized.
Chrono Trigger Musik.
Beste Song aus Chrono Trigger ist immer noch der hier.
Der hier.
Beste.
Huge.
Warum update das so ewig?
Beste.
Der Chrono Trigger Soundtrack, also an dem Spiel stimmt wirklich fast alles.
Story ist nice, die Nebenquests sind nice.
Der Soundtrack ist geil, das Kampfsystem ist geil, die Länge ist geil.
Es hat eine super krasse Überraschung drinne.
Also ohne Scheiße.
Ich weiß, das Spiel ist älter als die meisten Leute bei euch wahrscheinlich im Chat.
Aber wer es noch nicht gespielt hat, Chrono Trigger ist wirklich...
Ganz ernsthaft, das ist eines der besten Spiele, die jemals gemacht wurden.
Full Ost hatte da ein Inhaltsangaben, weil die haben so geile...
Das Main Theme allein schon ist übelst huge.
Das wird leise.
Höchst, höchst.
Und auch eine richtig coole Compilation, die ich letztens gehört habe.
Jetzt nicht Chrono Trigger, sondern Elder Scrolls.
Das ist so ein Fan-Projekt.
Aber das ist auch cool.
Kann man gleich viel besser installen dabei.
Also es gibt schon wirklich auch herausragende Spiele, Musik.
Und ich meine es nicht unbedingt so das dick aufgetragene Hans Zimmer-Geschichte da aus MW2, sondern wirklich richtig nice.
Das ist mein Jaro.
Oh, bam, gut.
Poggers-Musik.
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, was ich machen wollte.
Ach so, dass wir anlocken können per SSH.
Das Far Cry 3 Main Theme, das sagt mir gar nichts mehr jetzt.
So, Abteil 3 kennt's jeder, ne?
Das kennt jeder.
Egal ob einer schon mal Elder Scrolls gespielt hat oder nicht, das kennt jeder.
Wobei das die Morrowind-Variante ist.
Bist du jung dafür?
Also Skyrim ist doch gar nicht so lange her und außerdem gibt's Skyrim für jede Plattform.
Skyrim ist was, 6 Jahre her oder so?
Ich muss gleich mal kurz gucken, wie schnell die SSD ist.
Ah ja, geht doch.
Geht doch.
370 MB.
Okay, kann ich mitleben.
Skyrim ist 8 Jahre her, aber das kennen die meisten.
Und außerdem ist Skyrim ein Game, was wahrscheinlich beim Launch auf der PS5 noch mal rauskommt, weil Skyrim einfach auf jeder Plattform erscheint.
Okay, anlocken per SSH.
Ich lass mal die Musik weiterlaufen und mach den Kram hier.
All authorized keys.
Also was wir jetzt machen ist, wir sorgen dafür, dass wir anlocken können per SSH.
Dass ich anlocken kann, dass ich die Systemplatte anlocken kann.
Und ich zeig euch jetzt nicht mein Private Key.
Dass ich Systeme anlocken kann, ohne dass ich die Tastatur anstöpseln muss.
Das wäre ja ziemlich, ziemlich bescheuert.
Das ist jetzt die Skyrim Musik.
Fussroda.
A cringe, Alter.
SSH Copy ID bringt nichts, weil das kein Open SSH Server ist.
Sondern das ist der SSH Server, der gestartet wird, wenn das System Boote zum Platten anlocken.
Das ist was, was eigenes.
So, das sollte jetzt funktionieren.
Also wenn ich jetzt Reboote...
Schauen wir mal, ich Reboot jetzt. Ach so, Reboot.
Ausnahme eingeben.
Wow.
Fuck, was war das?
Es hing.
Okay, gucken wir mal. Der müsste jetzt eigentlich sagen,
Hallo, ich rufe mir eine ALP ab und will, dass du mich anlockst.
Schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Ja.
10125, jetzt kann ich den anlocken.
Das heißt, ich brauche jetzt keine Tastatur mehr dran.
Deswegen habe ich auch das Strict Horse Key Checking gemacht.
Zack, jetzt bin ich drauf.
Das ist jetzt nur ein Menü, das ist noch kein vollständiges Linux-Horse-Geboote.
Das ist nur so eine Minimal-Shell, in der ich meine Platten anlocken kann.
So, und jetzt sieht man, nachdem ich das gemacht habe,
Boote da weiter.
Ohne...
Das ist eine ganz wichtige Geschichte, weil wenn ich die Platte voll verschlüsselt habe,
will ich ja nicht zum Systemstarten jedes Mal eine Tastatur anschließen müssen.
Okay, machen wir mal weiter. Weiter nice Musik.
Final Fantasy 6 hatte auch richtig nice Musik.
Allerdings auch ein bisschen...
Das ist cool. Ein bisschen ekliges Gedudel drinne.
Final Fantasy hatte das da, glaube ich.
Eines der nicest Battle-Themes überhaupt.
Ja, ich glaube, das, oder?
Nee, das meine ich nicht.
Ich glaube, ich meine das normale.
Nee, das meine ich auch nicht. Na, egal.
Aber die anderen sind auch echt nice. Ups.
Das hatten wir gerade schon.
Das ist über VM, ja.
Nee, nee, also das sind nicht beides VMs.
Das da ist ein echter Rechner, der hier neben mir steht.
Ah, da geht mir das Herz auf bei solcher Musik.
Also vor allem halt wegen den Games.
From night into day. Keine Ahnung.
Hero away, wie auch immer der Text ging.
Evening Star. Irgendwas mit Evening Star kommt im Text jetzt. Keine Ahnung.
Joma Starlight. Ich kann den Text nicht mehr.
Das ist übeles Cringe-Text übrigens, ne?
Es gibt so eine Oper-Szene in dem Game.
Da singen die halt irgendwie so ein Love-Song.
Das ist eigentlich übertrieben cringe.
Aber irgendwie merkt man sich trotzdem.
Ich weiß, das ist alles Games, bevor die meisten Leute geboren waren, aber trotzdem.
Ah, ist die IP gewechselt?
Fuck.
Hä?
Ist die IP irgendwie gewechselt?
Hä? Fuck.
Hä?
Ich muss vor allem raudern nachgucken, was das Ding jetzt für eine IP gekriegt hat.
Warum kriegt die überhaupt eine andere IP? Was soll das?
Wird geraudet.
Leases.
130? Warum kriegt das random einfach neue IPs?
Okay, was auch immer.
Nutz doch den DHCP. Ne, das ist Loop-Style.
Außerdem, updated, das hab ich nicht eingestellt, dass der DHCP-Adressen vergibt und DNS-updated.
Was hältst du von Manjaro als zu essen in Windows? Top, ich hab ja auch Manjaro.
Moment, die hatten doch hier so das übelste, nice...
Das da?
Nein.
Die hatten doch so ein richtig nicees Town-Theme noch.
Oh.
Ah, weiß ich nicht.
Weil, das hatten wir grad schon. Das ist auch sehr nice.
So, wir haben neu gestartet, wir haben die Platte unlockt.
Jetzt kann ich ja noch ein bisschen was machen. Wir haben ja noch ein paar Minuten Zeit.
So, ich wollte mal Temperatur gucken.
Sensors einfach nur, ne.
LM-Sensors.
Wie warm das Ganze ist.
Wobei, das hatten wir grad schon. Wir machen mal lieber den, wir machen mal den Soundtrack weiter.
Ja, das ist eindeutig Chrono Trigords.
Die anderen Sachen danach kenn ich nicht.
Zockst du gerne Cort?
Mal gucken, wie es wird. Kann man ja jetzt schlecht sagen.
So.
Gucken, wie warm das Ding ist. Ist ja nix.
Mal ein bisschen CPU-Last verursachen hier. Mal ein bisschen CPU-Last machen.
Oh.
Bam.
Gucken, wie warm es jetzt wird.
Wirklich warm wird es nicht, oder? Das Ding ist passiv gekühlt. Hat eigentlich eine ganz gute Rechenleistung.
Also für das, was es kostet. Wie gesagt, 65 Euro pro Board. Inklusive CPU. Inklusive CPU.
Nicht das Board, 65 Euro. Das Board, inklusive CPU, 65 Euro.
Doch ganz okay.
Das ist halt Low Power, Low Budget.
16G RAM.
Boktisch Keter. Was ist Keter?
Wie heißt das denn? Leute, das ist nix für den Desktop-Bereich. Das ist für Low Power-Systeme.
Das da.
S-Rock.
Das hier.
Das reicht für alles, was du nebenbei laufen lassen willst. Solange du nicht Videos transkoden willst oder so.
Hier, 79 kostet es jetzt. Aber wir müssen mal gucken. Dazu gibt es jetzt 65.
Hardware-Auflistung? Nee, nicht so wirklich.
Das habe ich auch teilweise ein bisschen aus Resten zusammengebastelt hier.
Okay, passt. Kram ist installiert.
Das letzte, was wir jetzt noch machen heute ist...
Sagt mir nix.
Ähm...
Ketamin? Was ist Ketamin?
Ich will als nächstes Großartiges mal anfangen.
Aber zumindest Home Assistant installieren können wir schon noch.
Doping? Keine Ahnung.
Party-Droge.
Wenn ich mich mit einer Sache nicht auskenne, dann mit sowas.
Okay, also hier, da. Da steht, wie man es installiert. Hauptsache mal irgendwas Curl in Bash gepiped.
Home Assistant als Docker-Container. Das machen wir doch gerade. Achso.
Wäre nicht verkehrt, ne?
Leider ist Docker so ein Wort, da spricht man überall irgendwie gleich aus, ja?
Weil normalerweise möchten ja die coolen Leute die Wörter auch cool aussprechen.
Also wie Jira oder wie Amazon oder wie Ubuntu oder so Docker, kann man einfach nur Docker aussprechen.
Das ist eigentlich überhaupt nicht geeignet dafür.
GIF. Genau, wie GIF.
Ne, brauch ich nicht, Chillfreak. Ich mach die offizielle Install-Script dafür.
Docker. Linux. Aber Linux sagt auch keiner. Die sagen höchstens Linux. Aber so wirklich cool aussprechen kann man Docker nicht. Und Kubernetes auch irgendwie nicht.
Ich warte noch drauf, bis die Leute anfangen anzukommen mit Kyberneeds oder sowas. Kyberneeds irgendwie so besonders geil aussprechen, aber das geht auch nicht richtig.
Azure. Azure geht schon wieder.
Kubernetes. Ich sag's euch eh. Ich sag's euch eh wie es ist, ne?
Dieser ganze Trend, der jetzt gerade angesagt ist, so nach dem Motto irgendwie alle Sachen in die Cloud verlagern, was ja viele machen.
Oder können wir das nicht in der Cloud lagern lassen oder wir hosten einfach unser ganzes Zeug in der Cloud.
Das wird in ein, zwei Jahren genau wie der Reverse gehen.
Da wird dir nämlich auffallen, dass einfach nur sein ganzes Zeug, was man jetzt bei sich stehen hat, eins zu eins so in die Cloud verlagern, nicht dabei es als letzter Schluss ist.
Das fällt dir aber erst ein paar Jahre auf. Das dauert immer ein bisschen.
Wenn man Sachen in die Cloud verlagert, dann muss man das richtig machen und nicht einfach eins zu eins die Sachen umziehen in ein anderes Rechenzentrum, weil nichts anderes ist es ja im Endeffekt.
Windows. Ne, das hab ich auch noch nicht gehört.
Die Musik sackt gerade.
Moment.
Was haben wir hier als nächstes noch?
Eins, vier, eins etwa.
Bis nächstes Mal dabei, was ich groß kenne.
Aber Kingdom Hearts, das Spiel mit der verwirrendsten, sinnlossten Story ever.
Das ist irgendwie ein wie Harvest Moon oder so.
Kann mir jemand ein Mini-ITX-Gehäuse mit mindestens 15 2,5 Schächten empfehlen?
14.
Reichen dir einfach nur Schächte oder willst du wirklich Wechselrahmen haben? Ich vermute mal du willst wirklich Wechselrahmen haben.
Ich glaube außer irgendwelche Storage-Gehäuse, irgendwelche Storage-Cases gibt es da nicht wirklich viel.
Und die sind halt, die sind halt zu teuer.
Vielleicht findest du irgendwas fertiges von Dell oder von HP oder so?
Hast du mal bei Geizhals geguckt?
Gehäuse, Server-Gehäuse zu bekommen ist schwierig.
Weil die meisten sind einfach übertrieben teuer, sodass du dir fast schon fertige Server kaufen kannst.
Aber ähnlich.
Ich gebe doch keine 350 Euro für ein Gehäuse aus.
Also ich habe aktuell ein Gehäuse von denen, aber das ist wirklich low-end, billig, billig Kram.
Und das ist einfach auch nur weil es so billig ist.
Und zwar Produkte, Storage-Gehäuse, Storage-Gehäuse.
Das da habe ich gerade.
Das sieht hier übrigens viel schöner aus als auf meinem, wie es hier so aussieht.
Die haben schon was, die haben schon Sachen mit genug Einschüben, wobei ich glaube das sind sogar 3,5 Einschübe.
Du brauchst ja, du brauchst ja nur...
Du brauchst ja, du brauchst ja keine 3,5 Zoll Einschübe.
Du sagst ja, du brauchst bloß 2,5 Zoll.
Da stehen gar keine Preise, ja klar.
Das sind sogar nur 8.
Da brauchst du wirklich den da.
Das sind dann 12.
Was zum Teufel willst du eigentlich mit 14 2,5 Zoll Einschüben?
Also ich habe ein Genpro Gehäuse, so ein 4HE Genpro Gehäuse, die sind ganz okay.
14, 14 ist halt echt ordentlich.
Der hat 16.
Der hat 16 2,5 Zoll.
Da müssen wir mal bei Geizhals gucken.
Geiz...
Das Problem ist, dass viele Gehäuse, die bei Data Horder empfohlen werden, es nicht in Deutschland gibt, das ist nämlich das Problem.
Es gibt richtig coole Nass-Gehäuse beziehungsweise Storage-Gehäuse.
Das Problem ist, dass du die in Deutschland so gut wie nicht bekommst.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, du willst schon den 19 Zoll haben.
Okay, Hot Swap Einschübe.
2,5 intern ab 12.
Oh.
Nein, nicht intern.
2,5 ab 14.
Easy.
480 Euro für ein Gehäuse.
Loll.
Oder so ein Genpro Ding, ja.
Die sind nicht teuer, die hier sind übertrieben teuer.
Also ich würde mir, ganz ehrlich, ich würde mir kein Gehäuse kaufen, was über 100, 150 Euro kostet.
Ich weiß, dass es dafür wenig gibt, aber ansonsten stellt man das zumindest servertechnisch infrage, wenn man was selber baut.
Weil ich kann ja nicht für ein Gehäuse die Hälfte des Preises ausgeben.
Die Musik sorgt.
Da gibt es sogar, da gibt es sogar so ein Orchester Variante von.
Ob das da.
Nee.
Das ist viel zu dramatisch.
Viel zu dramatisch, Alter.
Ich glaube, das ist das Townsteam gewesen.
Ein bisschen Metal zum Einschlafen.
Ja, genau.
150 Euro kann man nämlich auch gebrauchten kaufen.
Das stimmt schon.
So, wir installieren jetzt auch schnell Home Assistant und dann gehe ich ins Bett.
Oder zumindest gehe ich schon auf.
Das ist fast schon gute Einschlafmusik.
Vor allem, du brauchst ja auch den Board mit 12 Anschlüssen.
Es gab eine Prime-Sub, habe ich das übersehen.
Muss mal gucken, ob ich sonst noch was vergessen habe.
Phantom1268, Dankeschön für den Sub, falls ich vergessen habe.
T-Bits, auch Re-Subscribe, zwei Monate, Dankeschön.
Ich glaube, ich habe alles übersehen.
Kann auch bald wieder Prime.
Sehr gut.
So muss das sein.
Gib mir alle Prime.
Ja, irgendwie gab es da schon echt nice Songs bei den Olden Games.
Es gibt doch immer noch gute Songs.
Aber ich fand die sehr eingängig damals.
Gibt es dem noch eine feste IP?
Ja, dem gebe ich noch eine feste IP.
So, läuft das jetzt?
Schauen wir mal.
Was hat er jetzt für eine IP gerade?
130.
Hat er eigentlich meine 10G-Karte erkannt?
Ja, hat er.
Npiss0.
Oder auch nicht.
8123.
Geht doch.
Admin, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Trade Account.
So, wir sind nicht in Amsterdam.
Wir sind nicht ansatzweise in Amsterdam.
Sondern wir sagen mal Detekt.
Ja, da sind wir fast.
Schieben wir uns jetzt mal da hin.
Höhe haben wir irgendwie 250 Meter.
Wir sind metrisches System.
Fahren halt Kram da.
Weiß ja nicht jemand, wieso Ubuntu seine?
Die weiß es jetzt nicht mehr ETH, sondern VENet.
Machen sie das?
Also, das ist schon eine ganze Zeit lang nicht mehr ETH,
sondern die benennen das nach dem PCI-Slot,
wo es drinnen steckt.
Nämlich so.
Das, was du hier unten siehst, sind irgendwelche virtuellen Interfaces.
Normalerweise heißen die Dinge jetzt nach dem PCI-Slot,
wo sie drinstecken.
So, next.
Finish.
Da sind wir.
Homo-System am Start.
Jetzt können wir noch das SSH-Add-on installieren.
Auch ordentlich drauf connecten kann.
Aber ansonsten, wie gesagt, was Großes kann ich heute eh nicht mehr anfangen.
Es ist schon ein bisschen spät.
Es hat leider viel länger gedauert mit dieser kacke Ubuntu-Installation,
als ich mir gedacht habe.
Was hast du dir gekauft?
Das Ziel war, günstig zu sein.
Teilweise alte Teile, teilweise neue.
Ein Low-Budget-Board mit schon eingebauter CPU mit vier Kern.
Eine gebrauchte 10-Gigabit-Karte.
Das billigste Gehäuse, was ich gefunden habe,
sind die zwei Einschüme für Festplatten.
Es ist nicht unbedingt so zum Nachbauen zu empfehlen.
Das ist schon sehr am unteren Ende gekratzt alles.
Ich meine, wenn man nicht unbedingt 10 Gigabit haben möchte,
dann kann man sich was schöneres basteln für die gleiche Kohle mit 1 Gigabit.
Zumal man halt mit zwei Festplatten auch beim Lesen nicht über 500 MB rauskommt.
Aber es geht und das ist das Wichtigste.
Setzt du auch einen Raid auf und hast eine besondere Backup-Schritte gegeben.
Also aktuell mache ich so, ich habe einen Raid 5 laufen,
bzw. ZFS-Raid 1 heißt es ja da.
Z-Raid 1, das ist aber quasi ein Raid 5.
Und Backup auf eine externe Platte, aber das passt hinten und vorne nicht.
Erstens ist es komplett oversized und die Backup-Platte ist zu klein.
Und theoretisch alles zu Backup.
Und Offside-Backup mache ich gerade auch gar nicht.
Also es ist alles nicht so schön.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, und das ist auch der Zweck der Sache,
warum ich jetzt so ein Low-End-Budget-Ding gebaut habe.
Ich will meine große 4 HE-Kiste ablösen und einfach einen einfacheren Weg gehen.
Hier in die Kiste, da kommt jetzt rein, man sieht es hier unten vielleicht rausgucken,
eine 2 TB SSD-Platte und 1 oder 2 14 TB Laufwerke.
Und zwar wird es so sein, ein Laufwerk,
entweder mache ich einen Raid 1, dass ich zumindest im Lesen an meine 500 MB-CD-Sekunde komme.
Oder ich mache nur einen Laufwerk rein und das andere mache ich an,
einmal nachts und erst irgendwie mein Zeug rüber.
Irgendwie so. Ich weiß es noch nicht genau.
Aber ich werde wirklich so die Low-, wie soll ich sagen, die niedrige Aufwandstrategie fahren,
weil die Performance so wirklich brauche ich nicht.
Das ist eigentlich total übertrieben, dass ich in 10G die Karte da drinne habe.
Nein, nein, nein, das bleibt bei einer Kiste.
Wobei, das stimmt so nicht. Aktuell hatte ich es ja so,
auf meiner 4 HE-Kiste hatte ich ja alles laufen.
Ich hatte Internetzugang laufen, Nextcloud laufen, Fernseh laufen,
Heimautomatisierung laufen, VMs laufen, alles, alles hatte ich da drauf laufen.
Also sprich, wenn ich meine fette 4 HE-Kiste abgestöpselt habe,
ging halt hier bei mir daheim nichts mehr.
Das hat halt ziemlich gesagt.
Und jetzt habe ich das Ganze aufgesplittet.
Ich habe eine extra Kiste, die haben wir letztens im Stream installiert,
für Fernseh aufnehmen, dann ein extra Raspberry für den Unify-Kram
und für ein bisschen ESP-Zeug.
Jetzt die Kiste für Nextcloud, NAS und Heimautomatisierung.
Also ich habe das generell aufgesplittet,
dass das nicht mal bei einer Kiste alles weg bedeutet.
Ach so, Internetzugang macht jetzt auch einen Mikrotikrouter.
Dementsprechend bin ich für daheim ziemlich gut aufgestellt.
Die Stromrechnung wartet schon? Nee, nee, nee, gar nicht.
Das ist deutlich stromsparender als was ich jetzt habe.
Die 4 HE-Kiste zieht ganz ordentlich.
So eine Raspberry braucht nichts, eine Router braucht es eh.
Die Kiste hier, die zieht mit Platte drin, wohlgemerkt.
Gerade 13 Watt Eidl und ich habe noch keine Stromsparsachen an.
13 Watt Eidl ist nichts. Wie gesagt, mit Festplatte.
Das können wir eigentlich noch machen.
Wir gucken mal wieviel.
Wir können mal gucken wieviel wir noch Energie einsparen können.
Wieviel Euro? Ich will momentan Strom investieren.
Ich würde es dir sagen, aber ich weiß es gerade aktuell nicht.
150 Watt, ja.
Ich würde sagen, so ungefähr in dem Dreh braucht die 4 HE-Kiste hier auch.
Allerdings Eidl ein bisschen weniger.
Wir stellen jetzt mal alles ein, was man power sparen kann.
Irgendwie spackt das gerade rum.
Und jetzt brauche ich...
Naja, jetzt nicht viel, um 12,5 Watt.
Das ist nicht so eine große Unterschied jetzt gewesen.
So, ich mache die Kiste mal aus.
So Leute, es hat doch leider nicht so gut funktioniert,
weil ich erstens weil Twitch gespackt hat.
Und die Ubuntu Installation ewig lang gedauert hat.
Wahrscheinlich waren wir morgen früh weiter.
Da müssen die meisten Leute von euch arbeiten,
aber jetzt muss meine Heimautomatisierungskiste wieder hinkriegen.
Deswegen Leute, wir sehen uns, bis zum nächsten Mal. Machts gut.
Tschüss.